here's why you shouldn't freak out about  olaplex making you infertile yes an  ingredient that used to be an olaplex is  getting banned in the eu because of  potential reproductive health effects  first off this ban has been going on for  a while the eu cosmetic safety report  that analyzed the data was released may  2019 the only reason it's hitting  headlines now is because the deadline to  stop using it was march 2022 so it isn't  like it's so dangerous they're rushing  to get it off the shelves now if you  actually go in and read the safety  report you can see that the ban is based  off animal studies specifically they fed  lilial in high amounts to rats there's  no evidence that lilial has ever caused  infertility in humans